queen is responding to allegations of
racism as part of the groin fall
out following prince harry and meghan's
tell-all interview
buckingham palace issued a statement
saying in part the issues raised
particularly that of race
are concerning something to note oprah
said harry told her
the member in question wasn't the queen
nor prince philip
the allegation of racism has struck a
chord in many british commonwealth
nations
a growing number of residents in places
like jamaica are now wondering whether
it's time to break
from the monarchy it's part of the whole
legacy of colonialism that we need to
get rid of in the 21st century
we can't be hanging on to the queen as
our head of state
around 12 million uk viewers watched the
interview
one of them good morning britain host
piers morgan morgan quit his job with
the station after making controversial
comments
about markle we'll take a look at this
new mural in washington d.c it depicts
poet amanda gorman
who delivered a poem at president
biden's inauguration the mural
captures that specific moment